opposers we get comedy when
conservatives see a guy slip on a banana
peel we laugh we laugh but liberals they
worry that he's been victimized by a
powerful banana corporation now he's got
a broken leg that he can't treat because
Congress is owned by insurance companies
he's lost his job his family and his
self-worth all because of a hilarious
banana peel incident the Conservatives
just laugh at that because it's funny
take it from Fox News host and the most
creatively fulfilled man on television
Greg Gutfeld conservatives were always
painted as humorless we were the shrill
tight-ass schools but now we've changed
the lives are the shouty humorless hacks
who accused everyone of ill-will
meanwhile who's having fun us for one
but once yes a sense of humor has
finally trickled down to conservatives
and there's one man to think Donald
Trump sure the left can't take a joke
but this guy proves that our side can
take a joke all the way to the White
House Trump
Trump's a comedy master Hillary
Clinton's earnest diplomat character was
way less funny than Trump's disabled
reporter but tried telling that to the
MSM they never get Trump's comedy well
like all the funniest jokes your friends
just have to explain them for you
the president was clearly joking with
his comments and the American people get
it they know he was joking they know he
didn't mean it literally it's just
amazing that people take seriously
everything that he says when he clearly
has his tongue so far up in his cheek
that you see it poking out the side of
his mouth yes thank you Mike Huckabee
for saying that not at all weird and
gross thing throw up and the
Conservatives have all the best
punchlines they're not afraid to
hilariously go after people for their
race or gender or their holiness of
their home countries get ready to laugh
are you legal or illegal either them
you're illegal yeah welcome to America
thank you you can stay all right thank
you thank you so much for now we're
fighting for the democracy
I didn't hear a word she said I was
looking at the James Brown wig I never
have a problem with anyone mocking
someone for the life choices they made
being Muslim for instance almost as
stupid as being fat oh man that bad
Muslim joke is Milo's who's on first
they say comedy is tragedy plus time but
who has time for time just give me that
tragedy now we have so much to learn
from conservative comedians yes Bravo
Jordan you're finally ready to learn
about real comedy I guess it's the
masters turn to tuck in his dick and
become the student yes Avery Jackson to
Josh sharp everyone
Jorden we see ourselves as comedic
provocateur yeah our motto is if we're
laughing that it must be a joke and if
there's one thing we know it's just
knock knock who's there a nice agent
here to break up your family you smelly
freeloading illegal hole the joke is
that the person's life is ruined yeah
but that's just one example intimidated
Jordan don't be there are a few simple
rules to make good conservative comedy
if you're going to tell a joke first you
need to choose a victim yes and the
weaker the victim the funnier the joke
are they overweight do they speak broken
English does their family owned fewer
than three boats instant laughter the
whole point of comedy is to find someone
who's less well-off than you and punch
down yeah just punch down and here's the
thing when you're the president you have
to punch down because there is no one
above you
everyone's below him all his actions are
beneath his office yes exactly
okay next up empathy is for Cox there's
a liberal myth about comedy that it
requires you to put yourself and other
people's shoes Oh gross
I hate other people's shoes and their
bodies and personalities I hate other
people there's no reason to try to
relate to anyone else's situation just
like good conservative policy good
comedy comes from singling someone out
for their differences and then punishing
them for it like when Trump goes after
megyn kelly for daring to have a period
yeah or when he calls maxine waters a
low IQ individual it's so funny and
liberals want to say that joke is a
racially charged statement probably
probably is if
like it made me yeah and now the most
important rule of all Hollywood please
hire us wait what yeah every
conservative secretly longs to be in
Hollywood if you liberals had just given
Trump half an Emmy he never would have
run for president he's not the only one
most conservative pundits tried and
failed to make it in Hollywood
like how Fox and Friends Brian killed me
did stand-up for 11 years not to make it
as a comedian but rather to aid his
memorization Skinner yeah
good cover Kilmeade or take Dana lash
who tried to get her own sitcom failed
and now she's the NRA s gun-toting
Dracula
come on Hollywood let us say we can't
end up like them Greg Gutfeld is a 53
year old man who thinks he's a little
Rasta and Jesse Watters looks like he
went to Duke on an axe body spray
scholarship